- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians!
Hello, Paige!
- [Voiceover] Hi, David.
So today we're gonna be talking about
commas in space and time
because commas have basically
one function, which is--
- [Voiceover] Separating
parts of sentences.
And what's neat is that we can use commas
to separate stuff out in space
and separate stuff out in time.
So I'm gonna handle space;
Paige is gonna do time.
It's gonna be sweet.
So first of all, one way
in which you can use commas
to separate space is by
talking about addresses,
people's physical addresses in space.
So the fictitious private
detective, Nero Wolfe,
one of my very favorites,
is supposed to live at
454 West 35th Street in New York.
So if I wanted to write
Mister Wolfe a letter,
and I would write him a letter
because he hates talking
on the phone, I would address it like so,
separating all elements of
his address with commas.
So Nero Wolfe, comma,
454 West 35th Street,
comma,
New York City,
or just New York, comma,
New York.
And then I would put the zip
code, which I think is 10001,
but I'm not sure if they had zip codes
when those stories took
place, but it doesn't matter.
You separate out all of these elements
with commas.
And this isn't just for writing addresses;
this is for referring to any
point in space on the Planet.
So if I wanted to tell you
the name of my favorite city
on the Planet, I would say:
"Ouagadougou",
comma, "Burkina Faso."
Real place.
I've never been there.
I would like to go someday.
And that is how you use commas in space.
Paige, how are commas used in time?
- [Voiceover] So commas are used in dates.
- [Voiceover] OK.
- [Voiceover] So,
I could say: on Tuesday,
comma, October fifth,
comma, 2010,
comma, I ate a cricket.
So, as you can see, we've
separated the day of the week
from the day of the month, October fifth,
from the year, 2010,
and then separated all that
from the rest of the sentence:
I ate a cricket.
- [Voiceover] Because all of
this is like a prepositional
phrase that is modifying the word ate.
- [Voiceover] True.
- [Voiceover] So we wanna
make sure that all of it
is separated out from
the rest of the sentence;
and we separate it out
using our friend, the comma.
- [Voiceover] Of course.
- [Voiceover] So if you
want to express a kind of
complicated relationship
in time or in space,
you wanna make sure a letter
gets to a very specific place,
you wanna talk about a very specific city
in a very specific
country, you use commas.
You wanna talk about a very
specific time, you use commas.
That's commas in space
and time, my grammarians.
You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.